más poderoso que el huracán katrina
luisiana se prepara para hacerle frente
al huracán aida con potencial amenazas a
las vidas y extremadamente peligroso el
centro nacional de huracanes advierte de
vientos superiores a 200 kilómetros por
hora el huracán katrina que devastó
justo hace 16 años a luisiana misisipí
mató casi 2000 personas y era de
categoría 3 desde este sábado los
residentes de nueva orleans se preparan
para una de las peores tormentas en los
últimos 150 años pensábamos irnos pero
decidimos quedarnos al último minuto
intentamos poner sacos de arena en la
casa de mi mamá y con suerte podremos
salir de acá aida paso primero por cuba
sin causar daños severos el viernes
antes de intensificarse en medio de las
cálidas aguas del golfo algunas partes
del sur de luisiana se enfrentaron a
órdenes de evacuación y el aeropuerto
estaba lleno el sábado mientras que los
locales buscaban irse otros intentan
salir por las carreteras
fui a la academia y compré una docena de
chalecos salvavidas por si acaso ya
sabes
espero poder traerlos de vuelta espero
no tener que usarlos pero prefiero
tenerlos y no necesitar los que
necesitarlo sino tener libre de nadie el
presidente joe biden prometió que
estarán respaldados por su gobierno y
que el personal de emergencia federal ya
está haciendo presencia en el área